[Music]
ryan is in salt lake city hey ryan
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and george thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so
my wife and i are just about to graduate
with our bachelor's degrees my wife
actually has will have two
at the end of april and i'll have
one hers will be in nursing
and
mine will be in exercise and wellness
and i'm about to start chiropractic
school in texas
now
my main question has to do with how to
tackle the student loans
of chiropractic school as they come i've
listened to a lot of your
shows on youtube especially the ones
having to do with chiropractic school i
know you don't have the highest
thoughts about
chiropractic school
but
i
am anticipating taking about 100 000 to
120 000 in student loans
and the reason that that's lower than
what uh the average would be for
chiropractic students is because i've
taken about
i've received about 32 000 in academic
scholarships for chiropractic school and
my wife will have a job of about 60 000
um a year as a nurse and so those are my
main questions
okay
um
also i don't know if it matters it does
matter my savings is about 35 000. okay
how much debt do you guys have from the
schooling so far
we currently have no debt up until this
last or this first semester of
chiropractic school we took out uh 10
000. okay why when you had 35 000 in the
bank
we wanted to keep it there
as a safety blanket
if
when we got to texas we wanted to get a
house or also keep it there if down the
road once i start my
business
we have it there for startup costs
okay
um
well i disagree with your strategy
number one i wouldn't buy a house while
you're in the middle of all this
uh you're talking about going 120 000 in
debt to go to school meanwhile buy a
house and meanwhile keep 35 thousand
dollars to decide to build a business
later no
no
uh effectively what you're doing is
you're borrowing money not for school
but effectively you're borrowing money
to keep money in your savings account
and you're borrowing money to open your
business later you're borrowing money to
put your down payment on your house
that's effectively what you're doing
so no if i were you if i woke up in your
shoes and i don't think you're going to
do this because i think you're going to
do your plan but um
so i'm not real sure why you called but
um
but i i would take the 35 000 and put it
towards chiropractic school i'd be
working while i was in chiropractic
school i continue to work on more
scholarships um and i would you know
your wife's gonna be picking up a bunch
of overtime to pay for your way through
this school
and i'd come out of chiropractic school
with no debt and no house
that would be my goal yeah i'm hearing
talk about safety and wanting to feel
safe and all this debt is not putting
you in a place of safety it's putting
you at a place of risk and when you get
out you're going to feel broke even as a
chiropractor even with a great income
because you're broke because you're
making payments on 130 000 of debt at
that point while paying a mortgage
payment by the way and property taxes
and insurance costs and home maintenance
costs so now's not the time to be buying
a house i want you to get your career
off the on the right foot pay cash for
this thing and later down the road then
we can get into a house so if i could
put
two of you on two separate tracks
and let's see who wins your track
or the track i just outlined where you
use every dime you can scrape together
and you pay cash and you work your way
through beans and rice rice and beans
and you do anything you can do to create
an income to get your way through but
you don't have a house and you don't
have money to start a business when you
come out but you don't have any debt
versus the plan that you've got where
you've got 120 000 worth of debt 35 000
in the bank and you got a house which
means you don't have 35 000 in the bank
anymore
um and your expenses have gone up
if i can take either one of those two
guys and i fast forward them 10 years my
guy will win
you'll end up with the house and owning
your business you might have to work for
someone else for a season to save up the
money to start your business you might
have to work for someone else for a
season to get the house bought but you
won't have any debt hanging around your
neck and every dollar you make will be
free for you to plow into your future in
cash and you cash flow the whole thing
10 years from today ready set go my guy
will win it reminds me of the tortoise
and the hare classic story but we gotta
move slow here and i think there's a
there's a lot of lies that we've
believed especially the younger
generations that dave we deserve a house
we've worked so hard to get through
school and we just deserve the right
i don't even i didn't even hear
entitlement in his voice i just heard he
was trying to be wise he's trying to do
all these smart things and he's trying
to do three different things that are
smart in his mind and doing them in the
wrong order
school
house start a business
and you're trying to do them all the
same time and in the wrong order and
hold this money and try to make this 35
000 do all that it's not gonna do all
that and it's the same guy who will call
five years later and say hey dave i got
a chiropractic practice and i've got
hundreds of thousand dollars of debt
because i needed to start it for
start-up costs yeah what do i do i'm
broke yeah and i don't want that for him
so alex uh or ryan i'm sorry you you
you're gonna do what you're gonna do and
i got a feeling just from listening to
you you're probably gonna do your plan
but if i if if i could put your twin
brother beside you and he worked my plan
he would beat you
that i'm telling you that's how that's
how the math will work out and that's
how life will work out